my father got OCD for I got liver me I'm
just trying to make it look right for
yeah I mean maybe I was just uh tell you
I'd do it though the other stuff is in
any Chopin GQ the first one I got just
just my breath when I stand I'm coming
since I was behind no love it really
just wanted I always have my own thing
like I'm all like I was coming to wrap
it with a group and I said I want to
have my own rice I must have fun talking
over nobody and this was my first piece
I was happy when I got vision this piece
is about forty fifty thousand dollars I
believe this was in around February so
you got all the last fairy yup it's just
where all the ones told 2019 collection
it's funny cause like all bad you always
been tied to one of is my money I did
stuff on the tail didn't business are
Jewish is not bust down like the ones
you keep bag
so these I want to say those investments
if I was about cuz like if I were
careful without the dollars or without
artist was been worth more so I feel
like it's a lot of time if you buy into
it like that you bless of my tears your
blessings always come back like these
blessings like this I look at the bear
bracelet as you can see this cookie
right here Bente you come closer you see
a lot of diamonds missing involved don't
even when I come off when you put it it
was hard when I first had it I'd be
trying to repair myself this last bit
though
I think this cheap this cheap people to
be around me to be making me take it out
likes it I like get it gives me a
Pokemon there's a really like like
protection if I was he had my general I
before maybe jury find everywhere I
dropped my China pendant before the
first one got come out to our material
and not to did I take on my jury I took
out my jacket my shirt and I just rock
out these are the more like the most
important ones because they just keep
you smiling you see the dump was I got a
little I ran through two groups first
grille is too big and then the second
girl Austin in New York I think I put it
in a napkin and forgot I put it in a
napkin and threw it away when I brush my
teeth I got a first my girl is nice it
was like quite truthful because like I
said I think I got a little CD every
Saturday I'd be personally in there and
I I burst from by myself brush the other
one by itself
put it down let it sit and rest it off
the high water
it's Navajo I put it on the look about
to have fresh my real teeth they're like
a number to my roots you get the war
speak and I put the grill on did not
burst I'm again
Oh think I suppose use wrong to face
potential court so you know did they
know you could take lots out get their
water speak pet that clot Talia teeth
make it dry if you have braces before so
you know you get a retain our
timelessness Iowa that solid really is
just like a retirement chuckling I'm 80
you gotta grow
yeah you could say therefore so he did
his time with these he all actually
caught me on a rolling loud true story
he watered soon is just showed the
montemagno large bright but he it pretty
much you could say they did he made the
stuff on the spot and I was cooking
crackers like I know that's a journey
listen I said Johnny L by D die or 24 to
26 K I ended up here 14
well my newspaper 44 and gifted it to me
[Music]
this is my baby
I don't know still write her holiday is
gonna turn green in the door I didn't
even know that to like I was in a dark
way one day and I said oh this is one of
my favorite pieces this was not gift
from Mongoose
I got another store buying this one was
actually a crack on my face when y'all
dime is hit hard you won't eat five cent
apiece
y'all flat news this was a gift for my
partner wife and loose am I really to
dibs off the neck and just get some lime
I stopped playing in one day occasion I
kill a village about for real it's
outside of peace solder is actually to
make entire of Jamaican but as you can
see I saw a Mexican flag over here
the musical flags for all the that I was
born is like a lot of Mexicans come
alive
Auto Street like Mexico this high I got
the nickname baby basic top of them are
oh yeah the top is one the shooter oh
yeah that's me
is this [ __ ] now my friends gave me I
done a little bit this one man shoutout
to go guys any little pieces of some I
see they always make sure I get them is
hard to me
does everything like like it you're
beautiful
I think I know religion I got my all
over this I got I like to wear it on my
jeans and I hang it on my building she's
late for my jeans you know looks way you
know the two feet so you had a true a
little being and I always got to go all
right your [ __ ] you're going you're
raised to it keep going
look dude I'll make it is this one
another gift piece from Canyon guys can
guys get the utmost respect for me this
is a different road piece I just feel
like this is all like it reminded me
like just parking like artists who like
those type of eyes like I was making a
date yeah big impact on me about so I
wear it a lot I love it and I cherish
I'll be [ __ ] with my boy be the yellow
beet if you have big and curly and
they're bad my boy back they got this
truck and the baby the baby he liked the
white go to I gotta do better to me come
on white already these come straight of
a bite real talk you can put this on
your bike right now and I [ __ ] I'll
bite work you from the who TV never rode
a bike Daniel on your by try pop it'll
be worse
I'm really one no inspiration to lose
the memory of probably know this is all
every time I try to hop on a bike night
you can tell it's been a while from you
is like it'd be a little shaken for me
in the beginning mother alright you know
I just took it around with it I guess
just he's got some diamonds on the side
so I just realized what's you think damn
well things it was a lie I'm teasing
juried I really beat it with whoever
telling you did
spaghetti spaghetti spaghetti this is
good old Oh God it's like we get
liveries be crazy
my liveries be crazy I wanna make the
writer is crazy it's writer it's about
to get crazy years left for me is crazy
right RIS about to get crazier crazier
there you go
yeah I thought about this bad boy in
early chop on the back doesn't mean this
white your lovely can you guys kind of
brought it to me I just brought a honker
but I got this today I got the masculine
bracelet with it today
I want to take a picture with a girl
well I gotta get some other ropes
I just put but I don't care about the
rose I get my ropes away to kids like I
like to give away a lot of my stuff
that's why sometimes I work out of my
stuff cuz I come back home naked but
this one don't have a rope because on it
was a lick here you know he liked it to
me I want you chained and I had this all
I was like I love what you always
realize that what I want the whole time
like okay get down with the hose you
know I made a little bargain with so I
gave him the rope he took the rope he
was happy as a mother they gonna get it
off me through cuz I I can't tell them
no am I here
well I look he bad thank you for
sticking with using them I know jury
collation
listen sunlight welcome hardest once
when we only look out for my debut out
tops out on the way
yeah